c'est devenu une routine depuis 13 ans
la conférence de presse du paris-nice
est programmée en janvier à l'hôtel du
département à versailles les
organisateurs dévoilent le parcours
officiel et à la fin deux communes d i
mean sont désignés comme ville départ
une grande et une petite ce 5 janvier
ses manques la ville vingt mille
habitants qui a été retenue pour lancer
cette course au soleil une boucle de
159,8 km à travers les yvelines avec
départ et arrivée boulevard roger
salengro le 6 mars on est bien sûr très
très très heureux on a candidaté et on a
pu donc avoir cette cette merveilleuse
nouvelle de pouvoir être la ville ont
seulement étape mais également donc de
départ évidemment ça va mettre en
lumière notre notre commune on est bien
sûr très heureux le 7 mars la deuxième
étape partira de la petite commune
d'auffargis direction orléans le village
de 2000 habitants étaient traversées à
plusieurs reprises par le tour de france
et ce sera une nouvelle fois un
événement pour la commune ce n'est pas
la première fois que paris nice passe
dans le village mais c'est la première
fois qu'il y à un départ d'étape de
paris nice nous sommes ravis ça va faire
de l'animation un village qui est déjà
très animée mais ça va engager aussi
tous nos bénévoles qui sont à toujours
présent puisque c'est quand même une
belle organisation on est bien aidé par
esso mais c'est quand même une grosse
organisation pour un petit village comme
un autre cette 13ème édition consécutive
dans les yvelines portera-t-elle chance
à ces deux communes libye noise réponse
les 6 et 7 mars prochains